human rights are one of the topics on
the agenda today at the comp 27 climate
Summit in Egypt's shama Sheikh
protesters have come out in force in
support of jailed British Egyptian
activist Allah Abdel fatah he's been on
hunger strike for months since the
summit opened he's also been refusing
water
with rights groups and his family
expressing growing fears for his health
International pressure is mounting for
his release
this is Allah Abdel fatah the British
Egyptian activist is currently
imprisoned in Egypt
in a desperate bid for Freedom he's been
on Hunger Strike since April and to
coincide with cop 27 he's taken it to a
more dangerous level his family are
gravely concerned
I'm here to do my best to try and uh
and shed light on my brother's face and
and to save him
today he took his last glass of water
so it's a matter of hours I'm really
worried I'm also here to put pressure on
for leaders coming
especially prime minister Rishi Suna
rights groups say Abdel fatah is one of
more than 60 000 political prisoners in
Egypt
spent most of the past decade Behind
Bars first being sentenced for
protesting against a ban on unauthorized
demonstrations and later allegedly being
detained by security forces in response
to protests against government
corruption
as world leaders gather in Egypt for a
cop 27.
detention has been condemned by human
rights activists the extraordinarily
severe human rights situation in the
country
becomes a global priority and is not
you know and is and is squarely at the
heart of cop 27 agenda in other words
yes it's about climate justice but you
cannot deliver climate Justice anywhere
in the world including in Egypt if you
don't have human rights protection
British prime minister Rishi sunak has
said he'll raise the activists case with
Egyptian president Abdel fatah al-sisi
at cop 27. Allah Abdel fatah supporters
have stressed the urgency of releasing
him as his hunger strike increasingly
endangers his life
for more now I'm joined by DW reporter
Aya Ibrahim who's been following this
very closely good to see you again
now we heard there in that report from
the head of Amnesty International
um Agnes Agnes Catamount she mentioned
Also earlier that three days ago she
said that that
fatah's life is on the line that he only
has about three days to be saved that
was three days ago what can you tell us
about his condition there's absolutely
no news about what's going on with him
we know that his mother is outside of
the prison in Cairo she would go and
deliver letters to him but today they
said for the first time the uh the
authorities at the prison refused to
take the letter
one can only speculate about his State I
mean the Egyptian president has said
that they will ensure his health so his
his family is rightfully asking is he
being force-fed is he being tortured is
he already possibly dead what is his
condition we have no news and as the
family has repeatedly said the only
people that can really give answers to
this as are the Egyptian authorities and
so far they have been silent
all of this is happening of course when
tens of thousands of delegates are in
Egypt attending the climate conference
Abdul fatah's hunger strike has put a
spotlight on human rights violations in
Egypt during this conference how much
attention is it drawing at the
conference well certainly not drawing
Egyptian officials the kind of attention
that they wanted when they you know
hosted this uh this climate
um conference I mean let me just paint a
picture about where this is happening
this is happening in Sinai this is far
away from the capital it's a beautiful
picturesque Resort Town historically has
been used by presidents as a place to
Showcase you know the regime conferences
Summits it's been dubbed by the Egyptian
government for four generations as the
city of peace and now
there's also been terrorist attacks
there absolutely but it certainly is the
town or the city where the government
tries to put tries to put on its best
face and now you have this the sister of
this very very prominent activist coming
to the conference and basically making a
connection between the rights of her
brother and climate Justice yesterday
she had a press conference journalist
there noted that it was one of the best
attended events of the conference so far
um there was a very uh hugely reported
incident in which a parliamentarian
tried to interrupt her and was escorted
outside of the press conference by U.N
security he was screaming this is Egypt
you can't touch me but he was escorted
out um the Secretary General of Amnesty
International who we just saw pointed
that what that parliamentarian did just
gives us a small glimpse of the kind of
conditions that human rights Defenders
have to endure in Egypt so it's
certainly not bringing in the attention
that that they want now we have
um you know Alex friends and allies
meeting with Chancellor Schultz for
example and now he has personally called
for the release of Allah and also with
Ursula Fonda line the president of the
European commission
Aya thank you very much our
correspondent our reporter Aya Ibrahim